[Musik]
wie weit geht ein mensch der beschützen
möchte was ihm am meisten bedeutet
reto fanger ist zu fast allem bereit
wenn es um sein kleines paradies geht
zwar hatte noch keinen menschen
erschossen aber die waffe ist sein
ständiger begleiter
seit 21 jahren bewacht der schweizer in
nicaragua eine mangroven dschungel der
ihm gehört es ist jedoch ungewiss wie
lange er noch in der lage sein wird
unerwünschte eindringlinge zu vertreiben
der einsiedler hat krebs
jemand aus der familie soll sein erbe
antreten das ist sein innigster wunsch
aber dieser wunsch ist auch sein größtes
problem
[Applaus]
[Musik]
unweit der karibikküste nicaraguas
befindet sich das naturreservat von reto
fanger
der 73 jährige pensionierte
mathematik-professor lebt ganz alleine
in diesem feuchtheißen sumpfgebiet
eine mischung aus idealismus und
verzweiflung brachte ihn
von den menschen hat er sich abgewendet
ich halte von excellent man musste
schwächste halver und die schwächste
sind jetzt die aeroflot und manche sind
überaus kaputt machen ich wollte ihn und
forderte man schaut wie in der
seriennummer
leider
reto fanger zieht ende der 80er jahre in
die abgeschiedenheit nachdem ein sturm
die mangrovenwälder zerstörte
tief betroffen kündet der
mathematik-professor seine stelle an der
universität in managua
er verabschiedet sich von seiner frauen
den erwachsenen kindern um bei der
wiederaufforstung zu helfen
was ich ganz ohne hbw trainer ohne
wasser kann es doch gemacht diesen boden
arbeitsblätter und die gemietet
hängematten auftakt das ist ja jetzt bin
ich total verwendet seien fließend
wasser und musik mit solarenergie aber
die erste taxi
heute hat sich der mann gerufen
dschungel mit seiner artenvielfalt
wieder erholt
2 150 hektaren konnte pranger vom staat
erwerben land das er alleine beschützt
weit weg von seiner frau
mehr als eine flugstunde von ihm
entfernt in nicaraguas hauptstadt
managua ist veronika pranger zu hause
die 67-jährige besuch zwar regelmäßig
ihren mann im busch leben möchte sie
aber nicht
beschäftigung aber nicht involviert bin
sowie netzwerk und im nachbarschafts in
catia verein und das bruchrechnung
in einem ruhe im quartier besitzt sie
ein gepflegtes haus
täglich nimmt veronika pranger per radio
funk kontakt auf mit ihrem mann
es ist vor allem viel gekratzt und
andere lied geredet aber wenn du mich
verstehst das ja gut
[Applaus]
das wichtigste ist
dass ich sowieso wichtiger ist das eis
wurde vor der heim nist wie in der
beziehung
lankern besteht will es ist ganz echte
freundschaft es ist ganz viel liebe und
des spiels kritik in ihrer stube sitzt
oder
die ehemalige kleinkinder erzieherin und
sportlehrerin lernte ihren rhetor vor 50
jahren in zürich kennen
das ehepaar hat zwei kinder
seine pflegetochter alle drei leben in
der schweiz
1969 verließ das frisch verheiratete und
damals noch kinderlose paar europa in
lateinamerika ein neues leben zu
beginnen
tvg außer mir sind wir gehören zu den
acht des ex general auf der barrikade
sehen die macht des 60
unsere
gesamte stelle ich eigentlich eh noch
gegen konsumgesellschaft und mir ein
gefühl kann auch einen oft welt der
anderen ort gut schaffe und eventuell an
das system mit helfern wird nur
konsumieren schweiz das ist ein moment
wo man denkt ein anstatt
libero sind neu bis neues ausprobieren
und dann sind wir nach lateinamerika
doch seit kurzem hat sich ein schatten
über die auswanderer gelegt reto fanger
hat krebs
moderne medizin könnte ihm helfen er
lehnt jedoch medikamente ab und will
sich auch nicht operieren lassen
was sich gehört natürlich
aber das schien mir nicht wichtig wer
jetzt ist es wichtig weil ich sie dann
nicht sterben wollen nachfolger aber mit
seelischen nöte 80 oder 90 oder hunde
die welt behalten und ich das jetzt
einfach an stress wie sie je nach volks
finde ja sehr sehr will weil ich weiß
ich habe immer sehr lang und
ich möchte nicht dass ich stehe und noch
ein wenig nützen
dass weise war zeit im untergang geweiht
wenn er sterbe sagte 73 jährige er
befürchtet wilderer und brandrodungen
deshalb müsse er jetzt die nachfolge
regeln
reto fanger denkt dabei an seine kinder
die pflege tochter und der sohn linden
bereits ab jetzt hängt seine ganze
hoffnung und tochter katharina
das war natürlich für mich
katharina die kontrolle übernimmt von
der reserve oder und das führt das war
sehr schön chemie
katharina pfarrer lebt in der schweiz
und arbeitet als fitness instruktorin
für zumba tanz
vor 20 jahren ging sie den
entgegengesetzten weg ihrer eltern sie
verließ nicaragua um nach dübendorf
auszuwandern
die 42 jährige teilt sich die wohnung
mit ihrem freund markus mair
47 jahre alt arbeitet als projektleiter
für eine lüftungs firma
ihr geregeltes leben ist nun durch des
vaters wunsch in frage gestellt
[Musik]
hat doch
entschieden ist noch nichts eine reise
zu katharinas vater nach nicaragua soll
klarheit schaffen
[Musik]
die ortschaft kokain liegt nur wenige
kilometer entfernt von reto prangers
naturreservat
[Musik]
veronika pranger begleitet ihre tochter
und deren freund markus
[Musik]
den greenfield so lautet der name des
privaten reservates legt das schnellboot
eine nicht fahrplanmässigen zwischenhalt
ein
[Musik]
katharina hat ihren vater zum letzten
mal vor zwei jahren gesehen
der erste gemeinsame abend in der
wildnis
jetzt sehen
wann du das was da alles so hat fasste
doch vorstellen da sich das nedved
dusche mit über dorf oder einfach und
ich mein immer du musst doch dass der
name konnte was ich am schluss der reine
schönheit auch im grünen musste sie mit
viel zu stoffen und sonnenuntergang und
sternenhimmel oder dürfen oder dorf an
der beta und wandel oder links oder
weiter oder eintracht und so das meine
ich mit dem aufhören der nimmt das wird
funktionieren
grad aushalten genau will ich die 2010
vom zumal mit der perspektive
überlaufen und umlagen und diskutieren
deren perspektiven unserer fans lässig
davos sind und dass man jetzt
miteinander dass länder plötzlich
fühlen und spüren
[Musik]
ein augenschein im reservat mit seinem
weg netz von über 30 kilometern
das vor 20 jahren stellen können oder
wie es im buch norbert hofer und da man
jahrelang im re berührt und krankheiten
so geht es rasch einigen auslaufen wie
soll man es mit den daten machen müssen
es ist ganz wichtig wählt doch selbst
der fluss und wann lüthi nach eemshaven
den zugang aber rasch und fluss könnt
oder und her zum allen ecken von der
reserve nun den controller als
willkommen hinein blüht vom dorf
oder so aber in der hygiene kommt darf
man sich den wir betrieben haben
dann knallte mit luft oder und dann
springen sie
sterben man geht luft für sich ein
hartes aber wenn es müsste die hsg frau
da müsste man kann mit ihnen und mit ihr
die besucher hatten oder sich
nicht durch
geräte da der ball mal zeigen will dass
sich die wertvollste kommen also ab
schäfer der ölpalmen oder
krank oder
männlicher
ich bin verliebt die ansatz ich mich
interessiert als widersprach damit der
ball war und ist mir wichtig dass die
paula du steht und dass man das sorgt
und sich ganz wichtige punk aber wie ist
das für die kategorie viel besser wenn
sie sagt
eine andere frau
also wenn es meiner frau ist der frauen
in der bildung
branche sandbahn
konditionen und mal ist so breit und
porsche
da wackelt und grüße vom stinkt und so
steigert ja du hast du schon oder noch
mehr war nicht so oft gern dreckig und
stinkt
wenn man es geht das gelände am auch den
ärger sehen die unsympathische bmw
markus maier misst sich nicht ein in den
entscheidungsprozess zwischen katharina
und ihrem vater in der busch werkstatt
macht aber auch er sich gedanken über
einen möglichen umzug in die wildnis
für mich
und uns lösen und schafft her
hin und her
reto fanger zeigt seiner tochter die
brandschneise die erkundung sein
reservat greenfield gerodet hat
da sich die schwierige van dyck statt
hand die runde die sechs kilometer lang
dies führe
dies damit wird an die obere große der
fluss und der zylinderzahl und
da sich die gefährlich stellt datum ich
zehn meter breit trotz ruhig etwas für
innen ist schlecht mal ich vorbei vier
kilometer hoch oberhof das kann die eier
je nach dem wind der tecnet schlaumeier
valery pflanze und sie sind wir
überzeugt waren betriebsplan zimmermann
zu stoppen
die news corp er einfach nur geld bei
der hera partnern und lorenz rebers groß
wie hoch das machen wir wieder mehr und
es sich für mich wichtig das ipad wie
die
nachfolge übernimmt will dann kann ich
in ruhe vergleichen aber die in die
pflicht und gesundes gebiss mit dem
latein bis machen nicht einfach
verfallen ihr konsumparadies wie nie
[Musik]
kleine krokodile leben versteckt unter
den mangroven wurzeln jaguare lauern auf
beute im wald schlangen und mücken sind
allgegenwärtig
ist das wirklich die welt von katharina
pranger
noch bleiben ja einige tage um sich zu
entscheiden ob sie das reservat
übernehmen möchte zeit die mit
anweisungen durch den vater ausgefüllt
sind
[Musik]
das ist
genau die ziele nun dort drucker genau
bin nicht so laufen
ja jetzt so in der stelle ich sehe das
so ne sein
charakteristisches aktie
also das herzstück von der solaranlage
und ganz ehrlich ich das den verso
selber setzt das auf 100 zahlen
tatsächlich sehr viel technik
viel haben sie in diesen tagen zu
besprechen nur die alles entscheidende
frage über die nachfolge schieben beide
vor sich her
[Musik]
das letzte frühstück vor der abreise aus
nicaragua
danach folgt
analysiere und bürger
und mich wenig also wie immer
das gefühl ich sollte ich muss ich bin
mit ihrer familie überhaupt können die
dir helfen oder als helfer mit green
fields
aber ich denke dass das der nächste
mindestens fünf jahre dass das nicht
drin liegt man für euch 2
ich bin entsetzt und ruhig will dass ich
auch so witzeln tiefschlag aber
war ein nachbar tag zurück archiv
schwitzen die über leichen so das völlig
der entscheid noch mal überdenkt
die hoffnung gemacht haben will was ist
wenn man den seite presseball action und
nicht immer nur deshalb ich dort immer
noch dass das dann vielleicht doch abend
ist unser grund aber wenn ich selber so
konkret dass geordnet ich weiß wirklich
nicht ob halbjahr operation oder zwei
jahren weiß es nicht aber
unabhängig von dem aber nicht gar kein
problem hätte nur sich mit 36 klar damit
rechnen was sich zb fertig ist und dann
muss ich zu ziehen der nachfolger ist
gesunder menschenverstand oder und
bayerische situation so dass sie
widerstand machen das müsste jedem fall
noch einen nachfolger suchen will alles
an der finnisch fahren wollen darf
mitmachen war tischen zu outlook oder
vielleicht siegen das wunder
partnertausch und dann die alles offen
klopf und ist viel besser war die
diskussion jetzt kommt aber nur
schalters grund muss zu zehnt auf einer
plane diagnose sind so dass maschinen
immer sehr lang geht also vorwärts
machen
[Musik]